welcome everyone to the annual Gandhi
lecture
we're here to discuss and celebrate Ram
Chander who has the publication of the
concluding volume of his monumental
biography of Gandhi entitled Gandhi the
years that changed the world here we go
I just got my copy though I had I did
read a previous version before
introducing our speaker and
interlocutors I would like to just thank
the people that have made this annual
lecture Gandhi lecture possible first
and foremost I'd like to thank dr.
Praveen but and the but family fund that
has generously provided the forum and
money for this event for over a decade
we're especially grateful for dr.
Provine Butz long-term support of the
South Asia Council especially given his
own association with the Gandhian
movement and the Indian freedom struggle
it really lends and has always landed a
poignancy to this event in particular I
also like to thank of course Kasturi
Gupta our program manager and amaryl hi
there for putting all of this together
and they of course wanted to remind
remind make two announcements one is
that this event is being recorded and it
will be available on the Yale YouTube
channel so you don't please don't feel
the need to record your own version and
also there is a reception a dinner
following this event which is just
upstairs and you're all welcome welcome
to join so it is an enormous pleasure to
introduce and welcome ramachandra guha
rom has been has had a long and
distinguished association with Yale
which we are very grateful for first
coming to Yale as a researcher and
agrarian studies no no no did not exist
sorry before I got into studies I first
give us a visiting lecturer in the
forestry school Oh wonderful thank you
and as you know the that was also the
time of roms first incarnation we might
say of his many interests and pursuits
and as an environmental historian his
first book based on his PhD was of
course a path-breaking book on the
Chipko movement called the unquiet woods
ecological change in peasant
since in the himalaya from those early
and of course a pioneering work but also
continuing environmental work rama's
expanded his domain and interest very
widely so from that over the last two
decades he's really of course
established himself as a major social
environmental political and cultural
historian and I would say many of you
may know especially the pathway breaking
work India after Gandhi
the history of the world's largest
democracy came out in 2007 it was an
award-winning history of India since
independence and it brought together in
a way that has been particular and a
consistent of this extraordinary ability
to bring archival breadth and depth with
punctured with us very interesting you
might even say IDEO focusing on
idiosyncratic and charismatic
biographical portraits of key figures in
that story as we'll see also in other
stories and also just written with such
an extraordinary narrative energy I
always remember reading that book which
it was it was a political thriller you
know of whether Indian democracy would
survive it was awarded many awards but
also it named his book of the year and
on many lists including the Wall Street
Journal of The Washington Post and The
Economist alongside that career as a
political historian and commentators we
know Rahm has also made his name as a as
a biographer so in addition to this
two-volume biography of Gandhi and first
and again extraordinary biography a very
relevant savaging the civilized very
Ella win his tribals in India of course
there's another incarnation we know and
many of you may know Rahm as a historian
and commentator on cricket and V so most
famously the social history of cricket
called a corner of a foreign field the
Indian history of a British sport from
2002 and probably most recently in the
last decade rom is known to everyone as
one of the most preeminent columnist
preeminent admired columnist and
commentator on contemporary Indian
politics regular with regular columns in
major newspapers and syndicated across
the whole series but from the Hindu The
Telegraph to the Indian Express
so it's a wide and extraordinary range
of interests and and careers of course
for us at Yale we've been lucky that in
addition to teaching occasionally for us
he's taught and many other universities
including the University of California
Berkeley the University of Oslo London
School of Economics but as we say we've
been lucky to have ROM teach with us
over the last two decades and most
recently I'll just end by naming some of
his most prestigious awards from the
2015 the Fukuoka Prize for contribution
to Asian Studies of course the Padma
Bhushan in 2009 India's third highest
civilian civilian award and for us at
least most importantly in 2014 rom was
awarded an honorary doctorate in the
humanities from Yale University so
please before we start the interrogation
let's thank Rome for joining us and
before Karuna begins the interrogation
I'd like to say how delighted and happy
I'm at Yale because Yale was formative
in my intellectual development and some
of the people responsible for that are
in this room but Yale also saved my
marriage and because my I was just I
just been married after five years of
courting my wife and we were living in
Calcutta and the School of Design gave
her a scholarship to do a master's and I
was left bare ft in Kolkata and somehow
the forestry school had a position for
me so among many other things I'm
grateful to Yale for that so just so you
know the structure of this event is
gonna be a little bit different the book
has just been released as all of you may
know and hopefully some of you have
copies on October 2nd here in India I
mean in America in India it was released
September 11th to Marquez ROM likes to
remind us a difference September 11th
which was the day of the burning of the
draft the fingerprint cards in South
Africa as the beginning of the
one of the major satyagraha in South
Africa so so what we're gonna do today
is I'm gonna I'm gonna it's going to be
partially a conversation instead of
questions for the first half hour 45
minutes and then we'll open it up to
more questions if in the middle of
anything that we're discussing you have
an urgent question please feel free to
raise your hand and and join the
conversation so the first question I'm
going to ask with it's something that
I've always it's a it's a sentence that
begins one of my favorite collections of
your essays and anthropologist amongst
the Marxist which I'm sure I've quoted
to you before which begins inside every
thinking Indian there is a Gandhian and
a Marxist struggling for supremacy and
and then it goes on to name a number of
Indians but I'm sure Rahm considers
himself for thinking Indian so I'd like
to start by asking him what if he can
remember what first kindled his
admiration or struggle with Gandhi and
then some sense of when you had your
first inkling that you would right take
on this this this project so um it'll
have to be partly autobiographical yeah
and I went to Calcutta to do a PhD in
1980 shortly after the first left front
government came there and my teachers
were Marxist of different hues you know
it was someone once said that I forget
who it was it may have been I think it
was a famous American neoconservative
whose the leftist Irving Kristol I think
you say he said once the most
interesting part of the Soviet Union in
the 1930s was alcove number five of the
City College of New York because in the
Soviet you really couldn't have debates
about Stalin versus Trotsky and Lenin
and Booker in and you know we have and
so on that was going on and the most
interesting part the most interesting
center of world communism in 1980 was
Kolkata because in China or in Cuba or
in Vietnam it was decided one way or the
other and of course in America by that
time if you talked about communism you
about Indians today would call
anti-national so there was a very
interesting incredibly interesting
debates going on between different
varieties of Marxism
sort of participate in that and of
course I discovered marks a great social
scientist and so on and through a series
of accidents I decided to work on the
environmental movement and I wrote as
you pointed out I began work on a
history of the Chipko movement and in
the summer of 1982 I went to go pay sure
which is in the upper electron de Valley
to meet the pioneer of the Chipko
movement and a Prasad but who was and is
an extraordinary value well the greatest
living Indians whose me deities he's a
social worker a reformer he campaigned
against untouchability he worked for
gender equality and he pioneered the
Indian environmental movement and a man
of extraordinary simplicity transparent
honesty and phenomenal knowledge not
just or is zero he's really an organic
intellectual who also knows the world
and I was really struck by this and I
came back I discussed my encounters with
these radical guardians in the Himalaya
to my max his friends and these Max's
friends to say wait a minute
the Chipko movement is put try to hug
trees to stop deforestation yes
and those trees are for the paper
factories in the plains I said yes but
one the paper factories create the
industrial proletariat that will lead a
revolution so your friend today Prasad
what is a reactionary and that first got
me thinking that there was something
problematic with dogmatic Marxism and it
reduced me to you know in a sense an
onion alternative or a Gandhian critique
and you know I think Marx remains a
great social scientist I think no even
in the 21st century
no one studying social science can
afford
ignore Marx but no thinking Indian or no
thinking American indeed should be bound
by box so Gandhi helped me grow out of
this and through these early encounters
with environmentalist there were others
there was someone who's better known
than 20-percent had to the extraordinary
made her part cut the read of the anti
diamond in central India who spirit in a
sense a globally defining role to to
emphasize the rights of those displaced
by last development projects but I keep
to writing about Gandhi much later you
know it was element had a it was to my
historical research Elven heard of any
problematic relations with Gandhi you
know he was a
he joined Gandhi here was a English
priest who sheds his both his religion
and his nationality becomes an Indian
starts working with tribal people falls
in love with that English girl who's
working with him and our rights to
Gandhi for Gandhi's blessings Gandhi
says fine you can marry Mary because
both of you are wonderful social workers
but you must practice celibacy after
marriage
so he abandons that Mary leaves and
comes back to England and so on and then
the element has a very complicated
relationship with Gandhi very
interesting unusual Oh almost 25 years
you know Gandhi know Gandhi spoke about
tribals you spoke about women he spoke
all Muslims he never spoke about a
devices or tribals everybody spoke about
Dalits he spoke about women he spoke
about Muslims but in Gandhi's
imagination tribals were some sort of
Hindus lost in the forest you know they
didn't really have a distinctive
cultural or social identity oh it just
emerged over these 20 years of
researching other subjects that Gandhi
was with me everywhere and I finally
decided I must settle accounts with me
very good and I think one of the things
that's really striking is of course you
started writing this biography of Elwyn
and I always think of India after Gandhi
as a kind of biography of Indian
democracy where India is a kind of
protagonist in that story but Gandhi is
an interesting figure to do a biography
another biography because as you know in
some ways Gandhi there are many famous
biographies of Gandhi Gandhi himself
writes his most famous book is an
autobiography he writes a lot as you
know he writes very publicly and he
publishes a lot so there's a question
you often you think of a biography is
unraveling secrets of some kind that
haven't been placed before the public so
I think so in a way it's a fascinating
but maybe daunting and daunting because
there have been so many and difficult to
think of what would be the new story so
I guess this is one of the questions I
wanted to ask is why you wanted to do
revisit Gandhi as a biographer and maybe
partially an opportunity to maybe say
something in the book you say you know
distinguishing this
from recent and one of the things you
say in the book is that the last great
biography was probably Raj Mohan
Gandhi's biography Gandhi the man his
people the Empire but before that would
probably go I mean you said these are
also generationally an older yeah set of
writers so yeah so I would like to yes
and maybe say more about what you think
biography does for you as a writer as a
way to interrogate Gandhi as a person
and what you think your biography what
what differentiates it from so you're
absolutely right Karuna that you know my
previous work had been in more kind of
how do I put it
most sectoral thematic subjects and even
India after Gandhi historians weren't
writing after 1947 so in a sense I had
no competition right
but with Gandhi there were these
hundreds of books and some of them were
actually quite good and I've taught a
lot so I was I was hesitant for a very
long time so I first I knew I had to
write on Dundee I knew absolutely that I
had to write on Gandhi and I thought of
but how would I do it so I first thought
I would write a book on the afterlife so
Gandhi
you know how he is interpreted
misinterpreted reinterpreted today
across the world then I thought maybe
I'll read a book called arguments with
Gandhi
you know Gandhi's arguments Marxist into
our bodies and bitkha rides families
then I said hang it let me do a
biography and then I thought it'll be a
one-volume biography and then he became
a two-volume biography now what
convinced me to do to think that I had
something to say in the biographical
mode what are the three things one was
that I had been thinking living and
argued with Gandhi from when I was a
very young man so I had 30 years of
reflecting on Gandhi reading about
Gandhi and reading also all the vast
secondly literature on Gandia as these
books came out I would review them and
think about them
the second reason was what you mentioned
every generation of Indians
needs a freshest estimate of Gandhi just
as every generation of whatever you know
friends people needs a fresh assessment
of de Gaulle and so all right so the
third reason in some ways was the most
important that in the course of my
research on the environment on Elbon on
political history even on cricket I
discovered a whole range of sources
about gun
that went well beyond the collective
works you know for example let us to
Gandhi the collected works collects
everything Gandhi wrote and it had a
team of very great editors the kinds of
editors you won't find certainly India
today so I discovered that they were
letters to Gandhi that were housed in
the Sabarmati ashram tucked away Lee's
cupboards and they were often incredibly
illuminating some of which he replied to
some of me she did not apply to but to a
variety of people across the world and
you know some respectful some careless
some really critical then they were
newspaper accounts intelligence reports
and I could cartoons just the cost of my
work I found that he could eliminate
Gandhi from many directions not just
from his collected works and finally
there was a very large collection of
Gandhi's papers that were in the
possession of his last secretary who was
with Gandhi when he died and when Gandhi
died in Delhi in 1948 this person who
was a devoted guardian called PRN al
decided he would be - Gandhi what
possible was to Johnson
so he went had collected all Gandhi's
papers but kept him to himself and
showed it to no one else
and why the corrected works were going
on you know the collect I at the same
time as parallel was writing this
multi-volume biography of Gandhi he's
never finished the collected works were
being edited in a different part of
Delhi and the chief editor of the
collected works a great scholar called K
Swaminathan said when it came to
guarding his materials on Gandhi PRA law
was like Othello guarding Desdemona so
these papers are open only a few years
ago so I had the great privilege to have
access to a very large collection of
Gandhi's own papers so I think for all
these reasons I decided I could I must
have a stab at writing the 500 and for
the 5000 first biography of Gandhi
whatever it is but I must settle my
account for the man yes I mean I think
one of the thing that it comes through
in both this both these volumes and
again I think as a comparison to India
after Gandhi is you so as as a person's
a scholar of Gandhi to the collected
works are daunting but also and a
hundred volumes depending on how you
count now but they also are just
one-sided so you don't
you neither get the correspondence but
also as you say Gandhi's as an editor or
a public editor who's writing constantly
in his journals these journals
themselves are also receiving enormous
amounts of letters and I do think what
you capture is in a way a certain kind
of contemporary contemporaneity of the
debate you know of how people were
perceiving Gandhi in that moment after
that particular statement and given that
he had so many arguments I think that is
one of the one of the things that the
this kind of biography which is not
retrospective in some ways it's really
trying to grow with each moment yeah
yeah so the other thing I wanted to so I
guess the one of the things I found very
interesting and it's something that
you've seen a lot of other books you
want to frame so I would say two things
one thing I think you there a lot of
your also your editorials and other
smaller pieces are interested in in
giving a biographical account of up
slightly unknown or lesser-known figures
of some kind and building an archive of
fleshing out the politicus Peschel II in
the political world but a number of
characters and and as sets of
interlocutors so not just a singular
figure but who they're in you know and
so we can think of just the names of the
most serious a recent series of books
human the makers of modern India as a
set of arguments and a sort of texts and
figures wider than just Gandhi Nehru etc
and dissenters and Patriots and
partisans so again a kind of opening up
so I wanted I wanted if wonder if you
could say a little bit about in this
especially the second volume the two at
least seems to me there's probably three
sets of these arguments that kind of
trace through the whole book one Gandhi
and at least in your version his two
most important antagonists the the
figures that he never convinces in some
ways are jinda and I'm Beth Keller they
they play key figures the others are in
a way the coterie of his closest people
and PR ela is one but really Mahadev
Desai who was extremely moving portrait
I think comes through in your book about
this you know he called himself a shadow
or you know
Gandhi's you know Gandhi's also sort of
shadow in the sense literally if the
person who was holding him up in some
ways but also hidden from public view
but I want to start with the third set
which I think it's you know the people
who are closest to Gandhi politically in
some ways it's rajagopalachari followed
by Patel and and Nehru and I think you I
think somewhere you say Gandhi calls him
them the the heart not Gandhi just I
don't know it's corresponding calls them
the narrows the heart hand and head is
that the order though heart hand in head
yeah yeah so near who's the heart
patel's the hand and Raja G is the head
so I guess I wanted to ask you if you in
your well to me maybe say you what you
think about them their interactions with
Gandhi in some ways and and the way you
wanted to present them because I think
what comes to is there actually we you
know they're all very close to Gandhi
but they're all very different figures
and they have very different
relationships with Gandhi and amongst
themselves so yeah so that quote again
you know this is the joys of working in
an archive what you'd find it was a
letter written to rajagopalachari by a
Tamil in the 1950s after Gandhi died
saying this one unknown Tamil just a
postcard I found residue papers you know
Nehru Patel Nehru Sardar and you were
the heart the hand and the head of
Gandhi it's a fantastic image you know
and of course Mahadev Desai was all
three but we didn't talk about mothers I
later I mean unfortunately been written
out of the whole story you know they're
all Raja ji comes into Gandhi's life
first because he meets him in in Madras
on one of his early trips at in 1917 is
when they first meet then the same year
Patel comes in and they are a little
later you know I think
rajadi and patella are about the same
age a little less than ten years younger
than Gandhi there was much younger for
law radhaji is the one who's the most
intellectually alert and sophisticated
and direct so for example while the
episodes in the book talks about
Gandhi's involvement with a brilliant
can gifted Bengali
writer and put called salad a [ __ ] or
Ronnie you know he was enchanted by her
and she was enchanted by him and the
question was where is this relationship
going to proceed and rajagopalachari
tells him look you have to choose
between leading the freedom struggle and
following your romantic instincts you
know and first-rate seemed to abort that
relationship though in many ways you
know that relationship hangs is a shadow
for a very long time again
rajagopalachari is the one who much
later I mean - good - in 1942 when the
quit India movement happens
rajagopalachari tells Gandhi do not
start this movement you know the British
will go any way they'll be exhausted by
the war this will alert them this will
alienate the Muslims it will polarize
the Muslim link in the Congress further
so do not start this movement narrow
says nook Hitler is evil actually Nehru
was an anti-fascist belt before
Churchill became an anti-fascist I think
this should be put on record and so he
tells Gandhi look the British are bad
but you cannot play into the hands of
the Japanese by launching a movement at
this stage but finally Nehru was
persuaded by Dundee to join the movement
but you know the other end of the hand
he says I am ready for the last fight
with the British and I would organize
everyone and he makes the speeches in
Gujarati going across you know I'm the
bad Bombay and says this is Babu's last
fight because Gandhi is almost 75 and
you must be with him so it's all have
very interesting complicated
relationships your Gandhi and in this
book actually in some ways I have
encountered index entries but probably
rather the end patina as important or
more important than narrow because in
most accounts it is this Guardian arrow
right there are extraordinary people and
of course each deserves I mean that man
Gandhi has written a very good books on
Patel and Rosati - and they're both top
class books but I think it would be nice
if some younger scholars would revisit
Nehru Patel and Raja ji and give us
fresh perspectives on them yeah I mean
one of the things I found just
fascinating one lasting one lasting you
know I get a very a lot in terms of
Gandhi's social policy yeah so narrow is
most committed to Hindu Muslim harmony
so he follows Gandhi most directly there
rajagopalachari although being a
sanskrit speaking Tamil Brahmin is the
only one of Gandhi's colleagues who
the battle against untouchability
seriously in the Congress party if the
only one would recognize the force of
America's challenge Patel is a brilliant
organization man and without him the
Congress would not have been built so
even in terms of Gandhi's larger agenda
they have different perspectives yeah I
mean I think that's what's so striking
is Rajaji is the one who is yet closer
to the only one yes as you say in the
book comes out very clearly he's the
only one who Gandhi knows that he's the
one to turn to to write anything on cast
or it takes his opinion on the ante
untouchability campaign very seriously
and both patel and never who are clearly
his successors in some form are the ones
who are more interested in they're more
easily persuaded by Gandhi when Gandhi
wants to act yeah they're there I mean
they're the the hand in the heart of
action yeah and of course in some ways
patel is the closest just geographically
in gujarati linguistically familiarly
but actually in in other ways in you
know as a as a he's neither the Hat he's
he's the hand not the head and the heart
it's interesting
and the final question on never which i
think is the question that still you
know in a way is still a mystery is in a
way dodging see again it's close you see
why they're close there are figures that
they come in to Gandhi's like very early
they're attracted to Gandhi Nehru is -
but as you know I think one of the
questions that always is still you know
profoundly interesting - to rethink is
you know what was it what did Gandhi see
an arrow yeah and you know we can I mean
maybe we can guess in some ways what
never given how in a way how so
sociologically they're the most
different got it in some ways I mean as
you say they they're both similar in
that maybe they're both both genuinely
India yes they're both cause of you know
cosmopolitan in their own very
particular way but narrow is you know
comes up in the social world that's very
different education wise and perspective
so what what do you think that Gandhi
saw in there who that committed him
maybe early on but also repeatedly to to
committed him to really believing that
Nero is the right air political heir
yeah you know let me answer that's a
wonderful question I can answer that
with an anecdote that is not in this
book because it's unsourced it is to do
with say Bagram ashram in about 1940 or
41 there's a meeting of the Congress
Working Committee and the war is on and
the Battle of blitz and Hitler's
persecuting the Jews and X Y Z and Japan
is mama and the meeting ends and
everyone leaves to take their trains and
as you know Dario is leaving cuz toolbar
tells him in Hindi but want Omar Assad
think God be with you
and which never loses his temper and say
what God would God allow Hitler to rise
would God allow the blooming knows it
would God what so everyone's afford
because no one has talked to Cristal one
like this yeah and Gandhi says to ba ba
don't worry halal is closer to God than
any of us okay it's a wonderful I don't
change the book because it's outsourced
but you know there was a kind of warmth
and charm and humanity about new you
know that I think appealed to Gandhi the
cynic would say that it was you know a
social climbing and he wanted to be with
that rich well well-dressed Western guy
like Moe Corral but I don't think I
think it was partly the personality
there was the charm and a warmth and
appeal to narrow you know and that is
clear but beyond that there was there
was what you point to Corona that Raja
ji was a conservative South Indian Patel
was a conservative Gujarati running the
Prasad was a conservative Bihari among
his other you know Nehru had this kind
of capacious vision you know I think
after Gandhi he was the one Congress
leader who was not parochial and not
just parochial in linguistic sense in a
religious sense also in terms of gender
I mean in that whole lot here is the
entire Congress party he was the only
male apart from Gandhi who believed in
gender equality and of course he had the
more radical reason Gandhi on that
subject and I think this must be part of
this you know all of this and also he
was much younger the fact that was
younger then then Raja G and Patel meant
that he felt he could take take his
legacy on further even though the
is it profoundly on science and economic
development on technology on industry
versus agriculture and he says very
early on that Nehru will succeed later
on he says after I'm gone
Nehru and Patel in that order will
succeed me so I think these are these
are the various reasons I think that he
essentially uh no internet over here and
also data was incredibly popular you
know again I said this because there's a
myth this is a kind of story that is
very active on social media about how
Patel was designed denied the president
ship of the Congress party in 1946 now
what happened was actually this there
was the secretaries of the PCC right
that is of the the secretaries of the
Provincial Congress committees out of
them out of fifteen twelve wanted Patel
but all had been appointed by Patel it's
if you asked you know if you ask the
beams of a university just to say
something about the president you kind
of certain kind of reaction if you ask
the faculty you'll get a different kind
of reaction if you ask the students you
get a different kind of reaction and
Patel you Patel you this is very
important I mean he says facetious
analogy but in the context but they knew
that the secretaries were loyal to him
because he had appointed them if the
vote went to the All India Congress
Committee we had 1500 members it had
voted 800 or 900 for Nehru we went to
the Congress membership eater what 85
percent forget there's a wonderful
anecdote in radmann Gandhi's book where
odd Patel where they come for a rally
and everyone is there and Patel says
what a kind of mixture of wistfulness
admiration and perhaps sorrow they have
come for Johar not for me right so I
think Gandhi knew all of that - yeah
yeah yeah and of course as a precursor
to their their their relationship
strategy Patil and Nehru and post Gandhi
of course is it's a fascinating set up
to seeing how they diverge a politically
after I mean one of the things that you
mentioned of course and this will get
back to the Jinnah and I'm both carriers
you say every generation needs to
revisit their these founding moments
these founding fears and of course I
think it's strikingly as you've written
about and we might all think about is
we're probably living in a moment when
the founding
and they were fathers their women to the
founding generation independence itself
has come under enormous public criticism
as yeah a failure of some kind and maybe
even a cultural moment in which
repudiation is the common right field
and so I guess and and Gandhi and Nehru
probably the two most the figures whose
public reputation
I mean maybe Nehru I think you would
even have said near who maybe had sunk
furthest or there's been the most
see-sawing of his public reputation on
47 - now Gandhi's a bit maybe it's more
of a I don't know I am an evacuation
know something of what God represents so
I guess one question I wanted to ask is
but on the other hand of course we know
I'm Bay Ithaca is probably the one
figure whose reputation is really sword
post-independence as opposed to the
contemporaneous reputation which was
much more bitter and much more negative
and also partially because I'm Baker's
he wasn't he wasn't a popular he wasn't
the same kind of popular political
figure
then as he is now and in the political
in the in the general political
consciousness of a much larger number of
Indians so one thing I wanted to just
ask is what you know so in that sense I
felt like reading this you know was
important that the you know well two
things to say so Gandhi is of course the
the great figure who talks as we always
say he talks a lot about moderation and
compromise but produced an enormous
number of people who were bitterly angry
at him so he talks a lot about how you
convert people and how you get them to
you know try to win them over the tries
and your people always write about him
being both wily yeah and they react they
either fall they fall for it as we know
the set of people who are just devoted
to Gandhi as we've just mentioned but
there's a quite a few who also never
never follow learnt people they aren't
people who are charmed and then run away
yeah it's either you fall yeah well you
you run away so it's a I guess I wanted
to yeah so and jinda and Baker seem to
be these two figures who were who were
always never never persuaded by the
charms in some form so I guess one thing
I wanted to ask is in the
a bit about in the book they sort of run
its parallel relationships but maybe if
you wanted to say what what you think it
seems important now those relationships
matter because they matter politically
those legacies of those relationships so
what did you want to say that you
thought was distinctive or corrective of
how people portray those conflicts and
figures so we talked about you know how
biographies are written differently in
different generations and after
finishing this book I realized that
Ambedkar Lou looms much larger in
Gandhi's life then Gina yes okay now if
a book had been written 25 years ago
Gina would have be in the natural
antagonist and America routine somewhere
in fact in attenborough's film Ambedkar
doesn't figure at all yeah all right now
just for example but even its quality
biographies denied you know in the
earliest colonies Gina is much more
important because that's the failure of
grandi do you not keep a united India
and that's the what of ambition of
Jinnah of the success of Jinnah but in
this book Ambedkar is much more
important more important and this could
be partly because I'm writing it in two
zero one eight and these debates are
live it could be partly because I found
a lot of new material in America so I
have tried what I've tried to do in
tracking the Gandhi American
relationship is as you say not use that
respective judgment but let it unfold as
it did in clear historical time and from
their first meeting in 1932 Gandhi's
death in 1948 which I medical comments
on in a private letter to his the person
was to become his wife I taste the
complexity and the neurons of the
relationship and they're both
extraordinary figures I mean I think the
book the ontology of mind you mentioned
makers of modern India it has nineteen
people and only to get a second innings
Gandhi Anna Baker right there two
chapters in different parts of the book
you know history place them as rivals
and it had to you know a a guilt ridden
upper caste reformer and the Emancipator
of his people they had philosophical
differences they had economic references
but ultimately I think the historian
must say and the Democrat must say they
contribute
jointly to the undermining of this
obnoxious social practice it may be a
major contributed more but no upper
caste Hindoo did remotely as much as
Dundee to challenge the untouchability
and one of the failures of the Gandhian
movement after independence is that no
one took this about I mean arou
as a socialist thought class was
important not caste we know of have a in
whom something is Gandhi's successor
never in his entire post independence
career talked either about the abolition
of untouchability or Hindu Muslim
harmony so upper caste Hindus after
Gandhi let him down but that's a
separate story but in the course of
their lives it's a very interesting
complex relationship and one of the one
of the you know historians are
interested in small things political
theorists think that design
consequentially what is all this not you
but one of what are the job that one of
the most joyous moments in my research
was to discover how Ambedkar joined the
cabinet so Ambedkar and Gandhi had been
fighting for almost two decades and the
Congress reviled Ambedkar called him
anti-national said he's an apologist for
the British he's in the Vice Executive
Council while in jail and so on Ambedkar
as you point out had a very complicated
and better relationship with Gandhi and
the convention and but yet in 1947
there's the cabinet of free India
dominated by the Congress and Ambedkar
is normally stir and also a Congress
supported member of the concert assembly
and the conventional wisdom is this is
Gandhi's large hearted generosity and he
told his even a folklore story that has
been told in several biographies that
Noro Gandhi told narrow and Patel
a freedom cake freedom cake has come to
India not to the Congress party forget
America and I bought this and have
actually even earlier writings also
followed this line but in that course of
his research I found some pretty
interesting that Gandhi and Ambedkar
were arguing bitterly through the 40s up
till 46 Patel and Ambedkar an even more
bitter arguments and is a savage letter
that America writes to potato saying you
elevate Gandhi as a Mahatma but firmer
he's a human being you know Patel wants
to forge a pact with America to sideline
to make to marginalize the Muslim League
you know you
and I get the Muslim League so he
reaches out Ambedkar and they have this
disagreement and it falls apart because
of material says how dare you Patel says
so this is interesting correspondence
where Patel is saying this is how we can
ally
you know our parties can join we can
give you these many seats we can have
this polish in favor direction but
having said that so we could certainly
become a compromise but having said that
I must say as a congressman I remained
bitter about all the epithets you have
flung at I'm Atma and Abed career is
saying everybody's a human being for me
you know and if he I have disagreements
so they must get them you know I'm not a
punk but he does do the tough but he
would have made that right okay no I
don't crave early worship people yeah I
did it so happens that while this is
going on it was an extraordinary
Guardian called Amrit Kaur a sick woman
who had converted to Christianity who is
was very close to Gandhi from the 30s
was in the first cabinet wasn't a
concert assembly is sitting with
Ambedkar in the minority rights
committee gets along with him and tells
Gandhi please bring him aboard and I'll
find a way of bringing him aboard and of
course as the biographer I speculate
that you know I'm bit here was a woman
from a minority community so amid
contrarily felt much less patronized by
her than by an upper caste male like
Gandhi or Nehru appertain right now but
the fact is that this is one of my
really interesting discoveries my blood
off you know it has I said it has no
bearing on political theory or world
history or whatever but I like the fact
that it was not Gandhi's
you know kind of it was not dandies
magnanimity but the intervention of one
of his alert female colleagues that
gotta meet Korean yeah I mean in fact I
think that that part of that story is
interesting on three accounts I mean
because as you say so there is obviously
between Gandhi and and bethere there is
there's a political and philosophic
debate and that's clear there are on
different sides but there is also a very
embittered personal enmity of some kind
of just and and it does actually when
you see those letters and forty six and
onwards
Gandhi is convinced that there's no no
way to reconcile with absolutely in fact
he and Patel is the one who
is trying to come up with at least a
temporary political solution and as you
say what actually irritates on base care
about Patel is that he mentions Gandhi
so it's nothing like what we expect as
you expect that but Dale again comes off
as someone who is extremely pragmatic in
these terms I mean he's not he's not a
part he's never raised any deep concern
about the untouchability issue because
also the most willing to negotiate with
them both care for practical reasons and
it breaks down because he mentions got
me the book on Gandhi so I think it is a
very different story where Gandhi is
actually more bitter and there's less
likelihood of him and Ambedkar coming to
any agreement when this when this when
when I'm bitter does come any and you
and it's not magnum and so I think that
is a very important correction but I I
do want to will start opening it out so
I just wanted but I wanted to see if
there's I mean I I do wonder reading it
to this end so both so I think Jinnah we
you know Jinnah and Gandhi Gandhi knows
why he irritates Jinnah in fact that's a
nice thing you say he remembers it's
like I think he's been a mad at me since
1915 when I told him to speak in
Gujarati at a public events said I think
he's you know since then I've always
rubbed him the wrong way so and they and
they're both Gujarati they're from the
same part so there's some way in which
they both there is he knows that he
irritates and I think Gandhi never he he
does he has a kind of abstract way of
telling us why I'm Baker is irritated by
him he said of course America would be
irritated because he's an untouchable in
which but it's a very up he doesn't
actually ever fully acknowledge you know
that Gandhi also is he's very personal
in the way he describes on both care as
being unrepresentative you know he's not
educated he doesn't so there's the that
I think Gandhi is still a little bit
more
he's not as self-aware about the
personal ways just think somebody cares
a very difficult personality and I don't
know how to reach him yeah in some form
so yeah so I think that comes off very
well too so is there something so the
the last
I wanted to ask was if you want to say
something about this side because these
are this is another figure as you say
that no one's written about and if there
was something I mean I I think the last
so to me the last the poignancy of the
last section of the book I mean there's
there's a lot of other things will
hopefully open up and more especially
the private the private live a life of
gonne be here that's there too but the
second half especially from the from
jail from the jail of the jail term from
quit India it does seem like this moment
where Gandhi's loses so many people he's
close to and really it you know from
from Mahadev to customer but you know to
see if Andrews Tagore all these people
who had been with him in this very long
period and and the last Gandhi at the
end is this figure who is much more
tragic in a way because he doesn't seem
to have oh those people who were his
route yeah have all disappeared John
some form so he's yeah so I think there
there is something where you you don't
is it's almost feels like a very
different it's a different Gandhi that
comes out of jail with a different
purpose yeah so before I answer that you
know I think you said something very
interesting and I think absolutely
appropriate about Gandhi in America that
he understands at one level the roots of
Gina's animosity towards him but with
America that's never so and maybe I
should have proved a little more in this
book because listening to you it strikes
me it's analogous to his relationship
with his children yes I'm Baker is 23
years younger than him so how dare he
though he's obviously God is a polite
man he still inside you know use the
direct confrontation a Hindu patriarch
and I suppose many in the Patriots today
may be myself included I have a sorry
okay I have a highly problematic me by
someone twenty years younger than you
challenging this way right so sadly I
just stuck with listening to you and you
know maybe I can't make this book any
longer but thank you for that comment
Divya had a column on it
thank you for it yeah thank you thank
you yeah so I think that you know body
was an extraordinary figure I mean he
in many ways the hero of this book apart
from Gandhi you know there many other
characters because he was Joyce Gandhi
in 1917 and since you mentioned Nehru
and potato and everyone here knows about
narrow and Patel
unlike Nehru Mahadi was a great scholar
of Gujarati Gujarati literature so he
shared Gandhi's cultural and moral and
linguistic world unlike Patel Mahadev
was a cosmopolitan he knew global
politics you know he would read
something and tell them he probably told
Gandhi about much for example you know
and so he had that extraordinary
intellectual vision but he was rooted in
Gujrat he was a man of great you know
selflessness he buddy buddy also as
Gandhi says I love you because you among
other things you cook such good kitchen
for me but he could argue back with
Gandhi and of course translate inter
mediate save his time from fussy people
I have a quote where someone says that
you know Madoff saved than five years of
Gandhi's life by keeping you away from
unwanted visitors and he was
extraordinary person I mean he was
really Gandhi's head heart and hand
maybe all together and his death in 1942
devastated Sunday and as Khurana says he
was really you know in many ways
ruthless and without an anchor after and
katoomba dies this little later yeah
yeah so I am gonna I'm gonna ask one
question but I'm gonna want to encourage
people to start asking questions so
there are two microphones so start
thinking of your questions and maybe
even if you're ready to walk to them to
ask and the question I'll just ask and
it will hopefully open up is one of the
things you end the book on which I I was
very curious because the book ends in a
way we're thinking about Gandhi's legacy
outside of India more than Gandhi's yeah
much more in a way contested legacy in
India so I wanted to see missile I'm
sure to come up in more ways but what do
you think you know what would we say
about his legacy in terms of you know it
you know Gandhi anism was in some sense
still a political force arguably till
the 70s maybe until the Jaypee movement
Vinoba you know these words
two different political heirs of Gandhi
obviously in environmental movements and
many other social movements Gandhi
Gandhi anism is there in some form and
in politics too Gandhi and tactics we
know are everywhere but usually not in
the way the game you may have expected
but but there's probably no political
force that takes Gandhi anism isn't
really a political force so yeah so is
there is there anything you want to say
what do you think of as maybe key
moments that were the I don't know the
end or the change of that legacy or the
what the Living Legacy or what brought
about a more profound contesta Tory
relationship to Gandhi so you know I
think if you look at the trajectory of
Gandhi's influence in India post
independence
I think his martyrdom in some ways gay
breathing space too narrow and his
colleagues to promote the idea of a
secular brutal India but then they
narrow died his party fell in the hands
of his family became corrupt and you
know there's been a rise of in the
majoritarianism now it's a different
some historian would have to write on
you know you can think of the short term
media medium term and long term
originals of hindu-majority anism the
long term is of course from the area by
the movement of the and the cow
slaughter antique a lot of movements the
19th century but the medium term would
be the Ayodhya dispute and then of
course the Congress corruption and the
rise of Modi so that aspect of Gandhi is
even the Congress wants to be more Hindu
then maybe JB you know you often in a
vulgar way you know not even in a deep
philosophical way right no one in the no
one in the Communist reads Radhakrishnan
Aurobindo for example right so so I
think that aspect has gone read at in
terms of his attack on untouchability
this the Dalits have owned as their own
and absolutely right and just that
Ambedkar as he pleased and II as the
emancipate of the that it's right now
gender equality I think this is
aggression going on the last 10 or 15
years so it Barry respects what is
attractive about Gandhi and appealing
about Gandhi is on the decline
I mean there's also some ones living in
Bangalore Gandhi and Nehru both commit
to the linguistic
they detested the idea of Hindi being
imposed on everyone and that was also
now facing a challenge but it is
interesting to compare you I just was
thinking the other day allowed that see
how Pakistani Street Jeana now Gandhi
died six months after independence or
five months did not die together a bit
no package studies don't buy a large
Pakistani intellectuals and activists
don't engage with dinner in an
argumentative or combative way you know
Gina was the founder we wish it live
longer if you had lived longer we may
not have gone in this direction you know
the military may not have come is coming
fundamental in major now on ahead Gandhi
is the figure of intense debate and
argument and actually you know as I have
written in the past that if you write
any kind of scurrilous book on Gandhi
it'll mmm end because there's no one
there to defend him you can't criticize
both harshly and go to beg all over
again right all likewise you know
Ambedkar in the Dalits Osama in Doha DC
so on so it's very interesting yeah as
you see there are elements in the
environmental movement in the social
reform movement and so on but
essentially but maybe the world will own
him you know you know it's it's possible
that Gandhi's fate will be there like
that of the Buddha you know the Indians
kick him out the rest of the world so we
are please we'll take questions or
comments so I have a question about can
you comment on how the rollit act
actually brought a lot of people
together yeah seemed like it was one of
the central points and yes and Gandhi's
role in that yeah that's a very good
question
there's a full chapter on it sagar only
alter it in brief and i hope you get the
book but next year will be the 100th
anniversary of the aurora cetera and so
the chapter or it is called going
national
so Gandhi in 1918 organizes specific
movements on agrarian issues in
Champaran and Kheda and mobilizes
workers in Ahmedabad and he's now tested
his teeth with cetera in India and then
in 1919 there is this very obnoxious
piece of legislation passed which
you know is harsh Celtic onion in
prohibiting freedom of expression and
give juries the power to arrest and
deport people and Gandhi launches an
agitation against it and there's a full
chapter on that right now what is
interesting like you know for the
biographer the details are important now
at that time the great Indian leader is
Tillich whose many years older than
Gandhi he was the Honorable lineage
who's been to jail and were in several
layers in Mendeley has suffered and
Gandhi's then he was junior to Tillich
in the Communist hierarchy now it so
happens that early that year Tillich
goes to in early 1919 Philip goes to
London to fight a libel case and the
libel case drags on and on and on
because the British courts then were
like the Indian courts now right so it
drags all and on and on and why do you
serve a Gandhi emerges as the leader of
the roller movement and it's
extraordinary movement all this massive
hindu-muslim joint support I mean I
quote some excerpts of people of these
processions everywhere going on in April
6th 1919 is the day on which they roll
that septa grab begins and there are
meetings all over India
a week later is the gel on wall about
Massacre Gandhi is actually going to the
Punjabi stop and the massacre happens a
few days later and then of course whole
country erupts and the British rule with
that Massacre British rule has no moral
like to stand out at all right and then
so 1919 is definitely but Tillich is
away what if you like had been there
would have written a thousand page book
on Gandhi who knows now so it's a very
interesting moment even in Gandhi's by
bicycle trajectory tragically by the way
this is a very good book on door alert
septa gras which came out fifty years
ago
edited by my former director Ravinder
Kumar
it's called essays and Andean voltage
it's a wonderful book it's a really the
first good social historical study of
Daniel movements is this book so I have
a look at that thank you for the great
talk dr. Guha
I just wanted to know you're mr.
Gandhi's thoughts on the likes of RSS
and Hindu
so back in the 1920s and how that
changed if it did so there's a section
so the Hindu Mahasabha did he of course
broke wood in the masala and the Hindu
Mahasabha detested him and through the
30s in the 40s the Hindu Mahasabha was
really a marginal force in the late
thirties sour God becomes president of
the Hindu Mahasabha and southern Kareem
Canty go back a long time if the first
volume I talked about the encounters in
London in 1909 and sour got absolutely
detest Gandhi he has a person he has a
personal hatred for guns yet indeed his
writings on Gandhi reeked of absolute
jealousy you know but it's a marginal
force at that stage now the RSS comes in
much later and I have a section of this
book which I urge you to read which is
about how the RSS is ideological hatred
for Gandhi this is based on police
records which I was the first to see and
these are this deal with the month
August September November December 1947
and their speeches of gold welker on
whom mr. Narendra Modi has written a
dilatory book in which gold worker says
we have to kill every Muslim in India
and only Gandhi stands between Muslim
staying here and going to Pakistan Amin
killed and people like Gandhi and near
who are stopping this creation of a
great Hindu State and we don't act like
that but we won't if we wish we have the
means to get them immediately silenced
this is a verbatim record of goal
Volcker speech in December 1947 this
does not mean that it is the RSS that
kills Gandhi two months later I mean God
say may have been a freelance but that
we don't know we don't know right but
the point is that this is the battle you
know it something else
again this is bringing you to
contemporary I don't operate in the
Financial Times over a week or ten days
ago just all of you are yell students
you can get it from behind the paywall
which I can so there's a operator I
wrote in The Financial Times on Modi's
misappropriation of Gandhi's legacy so
there is nothing in Prime Minister's
ideological organizational training to
prepare him for anything but
registration of Gandhi but our primary
stirs an ambitious and intelligent man
and he knows that Gandhi is the only
Indian recognized globally so he's now
started a Gandhi 11150 and he's invoking
him here and there and so on but the
word use are profoundly incompatible
there can be no meeting ground on all
the question of you know the RSS wants
to create a Hindu Pakistan and Gandhi
gave His life to oppose that dish so
only such a pleasure - sorry always hear
you speak just wanted to ask you
clarification comment just a question on
the linguistic pluralism aspect
yeah because my understanding of Gandhi
was that he was in favor of having Hindi
as the Raj Basha not the Rashtriya
passion about 15 years 16 years after
the English leave if anything it was in
his debates with to God and Tagore was
saying that this should not be the case
so why would you say that I mean oh yeah
good question the dementia Tagore had
described in great length in this book
the debates with Tagore addressed and
they again extraordinary and very rich
debates there's a slight difference
between what you said in what actually
happened but it's very important to go
into this Gandhi was opposed to the
English language and he said that's a
mark of slavery and so Tagore said
absolutely not you know and he said you
know you can learn English and this the
world and you can speak Bengali or Hindi
and Gandhi was at that at the beginning
of that debate Gandhi was a bit of a
xenophobe
and he moves towards a more inclusive
cosmopolitan position through his
debates at the world later on Gandhi
says that once India becomes independent
every major language will have its own
state so he reconstitutes the Congress
from being the Bombay presidency
Congress in the Madras Presidency
Congress in the Bengal presidency
Congress to being the Maratha Congress
the Kannada Congress
Malayalam Congress and so on right so
but he thinks that he will be a link
language he wants every Indian to learn
Hindi
of course he does that right but he does
not want it to be imposed in this way
and of course
his great disciple tragedy in 1937 he
becomes for chief minister Madras and
promotes Hindi because Gandhi believes
every Indian every South Indian must
learn Hindi the Tamils oppose it and
there's a lot of raggedy than two years
due to the mid-surface
but the late 1950s other the changes his
mind and opposes indi and says that if
we must learn our own language but if we
need a link language it must be English
because it's neutral and this is in a
later book there's a wonderful debate
within him and and oh yeah you know
which is then make it make us about in
India and again a wonderful line of
erotic valisari is when the Hindi
zealots are imposing Indian South India
he says if Saraswathi was the goddess of
language she gave birth to all languages
including English which I like very much
better yeah yeah thank you thank you so
much for your talk your work and this
new biography I have nothing but great
admiration for Gandhi and and for his
life work and his influence on King I'm
so I'm raising something that might be
awkward but you answered it at LSE a few
days ago Guardian reported on it
yeah and I'm asking it because my
students are now asking about it and yet
so this is his tendency in later years
to sleep with women and who would make
one woman one okay yeah good but and you
said then that in that LSE responds that
it's inexplicable and inexcusable that's
I very much appreciate and I just wonder
for the sake of my students who are
asking about this as well what what else
might you yes so there's a whole chapter
on that it's called the strangest
experiment that's what the title is
which is an allusion to which an
allusion to Gandhi's autobiography right
now of course it's inexplicable it's
indefensible as a historian I have a new
piece of information to share for the
first time in this book this was his
grandniece
who saw him as a mother she wrote you
know Gandhi in fact that I know what you
saw that piece in the guy did miss talks
about some of this right now she there
was someone in Gandhi's ashram who was
lusting after this young woman and was
insisting that that she marry him they
have sex and so on and she wanted to
trust her trust test her celibacy - I
hadn't read in this you know in the
dungeon world now its but at the same
time even if she wore was partaking in
this experiment it was clearly
asymmetrical because of AIDS and
familial and all of that so absolutely I
call it the strangest experiment and it
was a you could call it an abuse of
power though he was testing his lack of
sex other than lack of sexual desire
than the other other way around which is
it comes towards the end of his life it
comes when he loses all these colleagues
and I talked about that in the book I
say you know Mahadeva told him I would
have told him are you crazy cuz - bruh
if she'd be all of that right so it is
and it is also an act of Verity you see
this the other aspects to this outcomes
are very debate in a minute you see it's
not just 2 0 1 8 and how we need to
reconfigure
gender relations now it's not just that
it's also something to do with different
religious traditions and this is
something I'll be the first one in my
book because they talked about Gandhi
embracing Brahma chharia or celibacy you
know celibacy is completely antithetical
to protest in the Protestant version of
Christianity and Islam and to Judaism it
incomprehensible even to atheistic men
and women in the 21st century who are
reared who come from that background all
right however celibacy is fundamental to
the moral and Theological work a world
of Hinduism Jainism and Buddhism and
some aspects of the policy right and I
think that is part of how Gandhi sees
his project he's greatly influenced by
his Jain teacher and so on but in this
last experiment also there's an act of
vanity which I talk about you know that
Hindus and Muslims are butchering each
other and
thought it's because of his personal
failures so he wanted to test himself so
which is why it expressible it
expressive explicable and indefensible
but it it's part of a very large and
complex life lived in the open I end my
book with a quote from the poet Paul
valéry saying that you know all of us
keep our lusts and manias to ourselves
then he made even those public right and
if he kept the leg out he does the
collected work led by professors why we
haven't put it all day
and as a biographer I also published
unpublished letters so you know like we
dr. King you know and there are many
things to criticize about dr. King's
personal life since you mentioned dr.
King right rightly so right both at the
time and later I think you have to see
this life in the round and certainly I
would not defend it here and there's a
whole chapter on it based on your
materials so please do anything can I
just follow follow up very quickly so we
have I'm gonna say one thing there's one
question here and one here I on this so
there seems to be two as we said Gandhi
lived a very public life and in fact he
wanted these experiments to he had
wanted to describe them and talk about
them publicly but I once read that NK
Bose refused to track when he would talk
publicly about them and he wouldn't he
didn't want them to be public but
everyone knew about yeah so but he
didn't want to translate each night he
wanted to include it in his despair
meeting no he talks he looks good yeah
he said the Prophet was always the case
though that the this were they they
weren't included I mean some of this
stuff material and NK Bose I think his
my last days those weren't publicly
available until the 60s and 70s
but NK Bose was his secretary yeah so
there were two people who with him or
both who who moved left over this and
both dead private and public letters are
coated in this later you know as we felt
that you know they did whatever and K
both showed a book it said K boasted an
extraordinary Gandhian scholar who wrote
this who did the first anthology very
first serious anthology of Gandhi's
nautical studies in Ganges and grant
apology I went to jail many times and so
on and then he was Gandhi's secretary in
Anarkali and he wrote a book called my
days with Gandhi
and that book his earlier books had been
published by Gandhi's own publisher
knobs even but this time Gandhi was dead
right Gandhi died in 58 little boys book
comes out in 53 he's submitted in loves
even and everyone said remove that stuff
about these experiments so he published
it elsewhere
now if Gandhi had been alive in 1953 who
knows but the gravity will suppress it
but the collected works put it all the
speeches today thank you thank you
doctor
go half for your wonderful conversation
and I must also thank you that I really
enjoy your work I'm a Naga a tribal from
Nagaland
and I'm so therefore compelled to ask
you a question especially in the light
of your comment that the first I think
comment on Gandhi really did not know
how to go about with tribal or Adivasi
so they were really not in his world but
I also in your book India after Gandhi
there was the chapter tribal trouble and
you have written very sympathetically
about you have mentioned about Gandhi's
own statement to the Naga leaders when
they went to visit him so I wonder if
you can imagine and I'm looking forward
to read this book if you can imagine had
Gandhi not been assassinated when the
army came in in indeed 1956 whether this
situation would have been different with
the Nagas if you can imagine that thank
you for that question
you know again these are things that you
find in the Kosovo research just as the
cost of my research I found that
Ambedkar is more important than Jena in
this book in the course of writing India
after Gandhi I found that the Nagaland
issue had been with us as long as the
Kashmir issue and as intractable and
these were two unreconciled parts of
India in which the Indian state had used
arbitrary and excessive force so I think
through the book it runs Naga I didn't
catch me right
so absolutely absolutely and what would
Gandhi you know it's a very difficult
question because you know I think the
other Gandhi would certainly have argued
for reconciliation you know but
seriously honorable reconciliation while
could this have been possible and so on
and so forth
he would have deplored the excessive use
of force by the Union Army but I think
even also deployed armed struggle by the
Nagas I think because that would have
been inconsistent in a sense that
terrorize what you should do right okay
so it's hard to say but clearly going
beyond Gandhi to history of Indian
Republic those are our two failures you
know in terms of us communicating the
legitimacy the authority and even just
plain decency in Kashmir and Nagaland we
have fake you know and in nagaland I
think there is a glimmer of hope now it
trust me things are getting worse and
worse and worse for complicated reasons
including the fact that there's a third
party involved but Gandhi would
certainly have if he had been in there
in the 1950s he would deplore the
excessive use of force by the Indian
Army for sure but he may have also
preached non-violence to the Nagas could
you comment on bacha Khan and the red
Redshank
army yeah there is some stuff for yeah
yeah there is a discussion about Chacon
this was a beautiful photograph of have
a look with him and Mahadev Desai is AB
you know it's it's a wonderful
photograph they took photographs of our
second actually as it turns out because
one a rally in in in the Northwest
Frontier Province in 37 with all these
Congress white shirts and watch a cannon
can be in the podium far away but is a
lovely photo of it's just I don't know
it's too far away for you to see but
anyway it is take a lot of morning walk
Gandhi's morning walk
but Shekhar is going to serve as RAM and
there is Gandhi there's one other
colleague who I could identify this
Bachchan six-foot-seven
with a hand around male who's five foot
six it's a beautiful photograph
I mean I don't know whether we can fight
it but there is a fact you know these
are all people who deserve their own
proper biographies I mean it's a good
anthropological study yeah have a look
too far away but there's much I can with
his end around body so I am you know he
was someone did there is there's a good
anthropological study by mu critic of
energy called the Pathan and armed
all right on the Patel struggle and so
on let me title to but there is no good
biography yet I mean I started corrected
if there people here from Pakistan or
Afghanistan but you know he was
extraordinary ger
he was someone who spent Gaza degraded
more in British jails and a decade and
more in Pakistan he says he felt
betrayed by the Congress because of the
46 referendum and what happened and you
know it was Pakistan happened but they
were marooned there far away so I wish
there was a biography of corrupt of the
park on as some other people know in
this book maybe I look for you
I recently interacted with an African
lady and she told me that Gandhi is
racist I was bit dumbfounded and she
asked me what are your opinion so I
probably I told her that my knowledge is
pretty limited but as far as I know
Gandhi he was a very dynamic character
he kept reading kept improving himself
the best example I told her that his
views on caste ISM probably he wanted
deleted the lead people to be part of
Hindu mainstream society whoever joined
his ashram was made to clean toilets but
somehow deep down he could not get rid
of his he still believed that it was the
rich job to clean the shed so that's
what that was my response I'm not sure
what will be your comment on that and
how should I counter
you can be her two volumes of my book if
you have the pieces but actually his
views on caste ball and this second
volume talks about that his views of
this race also evolve when he goes to
South Africa 1893 he's a racist as a 23
year old Indian is a racist but he shed
some of his prejudices in South Africa
he said them further and further when he
comes back to India and I described it
this book
visits my African Americans to him in
his ashram and what they take back one
of them is the great Howard Thurman who
was a mentor to King later so they're
okay you know yeah it's Calabrian cent
Lee's shed his racism he changes his
mind all this right my books are very
fact but please read a short book by
Anil Nuria called the African Gandhi I
think it's called it's a very good book
it's about 60 or 80 pages it'll be there
in the air lab it's not me they all line
to which and ask your friend to read
that book after you read it after you
ready yeah thank you run for a really
excellent presentation I have two brief
questions one that as you've so
beautifully described very intelligent
discussions debates both within parties
mainly the Congress party among whatever
very tall men in a sense not by height
but intellect and so on we have a
complete absence today of any kind of
intelligent debate yeah either within
parties yeah or a cross-party correct
how is it that there was so many people
during that whole period who respected
each other had great differences but
could discuss and debate intelligent we
can't do that now
and there's a second observer suggestion
maybe you should now take up a project
to narrow rescues reputation what
somebody's somebody's at somebody better
qualified that means that work on the
second and we hope to see his work soon
Karuna knows who it is so I think we
have some fine scholars working on a
room and rescued arrows repetition and
separate him from his descendants I'd
allow me to tell one of my favorite
lines on this which comes from my great
mentors
soldiers and repete who said that naruse
posthumous career reverses the biblical
injunction the sevens of the sins of
seven successive generations have been
retrospectively visited on the I think
but somebody's at work on it so did I
work out that all the first you know
that's a that would have a did a
separate discussion there many reasons
you know I think part of it could just
be historical Rakesh you know Khalid I
used the term founders and I've used the
same term you know the American founders
I mean they had rich and productive
debates
I'm sure the French Revolution reached
and productive debates in the twenties
and thirties in China rich and
productive debates when Edition is
formed is formalized its consolidates
itself debate moves outside the realm of
politics into the Academy and Social
Work and journalism and thinkers so part
of it just may be that but every other
reasons may be the structure of Indian
politics that you have to be incredibly
rich and corrupt to become an MP or the
son of somebody incredibly rich in
character right so they obviously
structural as well as historical reasons
for this but narrow needs to be rescued
but I still believe that a fair and
proper and just appraisal of Nehru we
should be received in a fair and proper
just way by readers can only happen when
to our Gandhi retired from politics I
believe you said that the upper castes
let down Gandhi in terms of their in
terms of the untouchables and their
policies towards them and I assume
that's an allusion to Congress so do you
think that's ever gonna change in the
future especially seeing the growing
power of the BJP in the RFS so I don't
think I was alluding only to the
Congress you know I was alluding to
upper caste engenders you know and again
there's clearly a parallel with this
country you know I think there's some
extraordinay parallel to t King and
Gandhi one of them is that the freedom
matches right okay
had white people too and there was a
question about the roller septa grass no
real secular sceptic I had Englishmen in
it right
so both kicking in Gandhi Stoke the
human being India pressure and maybe
they touched 5% or 10% doesn't matter
right
but so Gandhi also Alda Perkis reacted
to this while he was there inspired by
him but then they betrayed him they went
back into their prejudices you know
their affirmative action happened and
there was a counter-reaction affirmative
action of all reaction all sort of
distorted forms and so on so and I was
not so much the fighting the coolest
party as you see it Gandhi's view of the
Congress party one part of the Communist
Party would run governments the other
part of one part of the freedom movement
after independent once independence came
one section of leaders like Nehru and
Patel would be in the Secretariat
running a just government the other part
consisting of his ashram disciples who
were social workers reformers who worked
on rural development on crafts
production on gender rights would be
outside the government doing civil
society activism that did not happen so
and then of course because I think you
know it's I mean if you look at the
whole I mean this is as a historian this
how I understand it that social takes
place a social change takes place when
there's pressure from above and below it
just as men have to be feminists to and
you know it goes up and down right with
every every few years you find women
organized from equal rights in every
sphere and some men economy and some men
ashamed and others are not at all so
it's an ongoing process and Gandhi would
have been deeply disappointed by two
aspects of what happened to Indian
politics and social life independent
after independence one is the failure to
absolutely insist on interfaith harmony
and the other is the failure to continue
the battle against the obnoxious aspects
of the caste
hyrum it had to be other things I mean
you're a democracy we have elections you
know we have more women in professional
life and so on you would not have been
entirely displeased with India today you
know but I think these are two things
you well you know worried about it so
what was it about Gujarat at that time
that generated so many important leaders
why Gujarat rather than other states
where can you name some well put
and Gino and Gandhi you know all three
of them came from Gujarat Rockefeller
Gerry Perry REO titãs from Tamilnadu all
right Fuli Ambedkar terrible Shinde
tillich bocalee from Maharashtra big
goals he siad us CR - boss you know etc
from Bengal Tamil of each other body
from my state the greatest Indian women
produced at one last one video could you
please comment on the nature
relationship that Gandhi had with
Kosambi senior well I have a long essay
on it in another book so please eat it
it's quite Democratic dissenters you
know there's so many aspects of Gandhi's
life so I have a long essay those of you
this brief background the question is
about Dharma and Kosambi whose son is
more famous than him the modal dominant
cause I'm ad Rico Sammy the pioneer of
Max's methods in industry so I have busy
that I say it's a it's in my collection
Democrats in the centers it's called the
life and death of a Grampian Buddhist
that's what it's called you know because
he's an extraordinary figure with the
Buddhist he was close to Gandhi he fast
you to death he probably inspired
Ambedkar to embed can never acknowledge
is it right he taught at Harvard left
how about to turn the freedom struggle
and go to jail even amazing amazing
person but one of many such people okay
wonderful well I think on that note
reminder upstairs there's a following a
reception and if you have copies of the
book like me you couldn't have Rahm sign
it and we'll just thank thank you Rome
for this wonderful conversation
[Applause]
[Music]